[Music]
welcome to the iron lords podcast
hello there and welcome to the lord's
minute our quick hit video series where
we talk about all the biggest happenings
in gaming and beyond i'm your host jedi
master tai swenson and with me today is
grand jedi master lord king david of the
crocs
obi-wan kenobi has finished its series
with a climactic battle between obi-wan
and darth vader as well as some
resolutions with the surrounding cast so
i'm gonna kick it off to lord king what
did you think going into this final
episode and how do you feel about the
show overall well first i represent the
seth
um
excuse me uh a traitor i.e the red that
i'm wearing on purpose uh
dolph maul needed his revenge
oh but this is not to be
i'm going to tell you
going into the series i really didn't
understand uh what was the purpose right
at first
but i understood that disney wanted to
explore
more of the lore of the characters that
they did possess you know that they you
know they acquired
and obi-wan
was probably one of the most uh
underrated
and overrated characters
that they had
so you know they did the whole backlog
with general kenobi and all that other
stuff with rebels and all that stuff and
you got a chance to know about him but
for the people that didn't watch the
cartoons because they thought you know
it was cartoons and it was uh childish
um you didn't get a chance to
know
how
his ways in the force right
so when you get a chance to start this
series you know that he was disheartened
he was like uh questioning the ways of
the jedi
all of that stuff the first time he met
vader
and he he found that anakin was still
alive
certain something stirred inside him uh
he started having doubt he started
questioning everything he started uh
questioning his actions and and what's
going on he it was a whole lot of doubt
with the character and
he explored that and i didn't think they
can actually resolve that in six
episodes to be honest with you and uh
i'm pleasantly pleased that they did
resolve it in six episodes
but
his journey
from the fallen to the found
is absolutely
incredible
it was night and day from the first
fight that he had to the last episode
that he did have uh in the last fight
that he did have with uh vader
and you know my wife jumped up and she
cheered it was it was crazy i was i was
disgusted
um
because
you know
obi-wan represents
all that is right in the world and all
that is right uh in the force right uh
purists
he always wants to do what's best
but you know even the the the kindest
most gentlest boy scout has a breaking
point
and anakin kept pushing him and kept
pushing him to that breaking point
and when he buried kenobi
kenobi said you know
because he he was fighting him as as if
this was his friend that he was trying
to save
and when vader you know when he actually
realized after he got buried alive and
vader left him for dead actually for
dead and if he didn't tap into his force
power
um he would have died he would have died
on that barren planet and he would have
never been heard of again but all we one
had a rebirth and he bust out of the
ground
and he attacked vader with such a
ferocity
with such a determination to actually
break them down
he actually did him worse than he did
the first time on mustafa
when he cut him
when he said i got the high ground
and you know i thought i thought vader
was going to say that back to him when
he was looking at him right right yeah i
was like this is the perfect time
to say you're lying back i got the high
ground ob stand down
it didn't happen at all um
but the barrage of rocks
that he hit vader with
vader was not prepared
for the full force of obi-wan
at all he caught vader
completely by surprise because he
thought vader vader thought
obi
gave him everything in that first leader
battle before right before the pit right
before he took him down and he was so
confident in the fact that he took him
out and he
he was easy he was light work vader was
really too high on the hog
and obi just really let loose because he
realized that his friend is no longer
there his friend is no longer in that
shell that is vader and vader told him
you didn't you know uh get rid of anakin
you didn't make me
i got rid of him
and that was the most telling part it
was heartbreaking
it was telling but this is canon now
and uh it it's going to set up so much
great things because you know then you
see vader at the end scene and he's
whole again but he still has that hole
inside of his chest
and he still has that anger that pit
within his body that he needs to fill
with the death of obi-wan kenobi and we
know
later on uh that didn't fulfill his uh
his thirst for or his anger um
but this series
definitely put a nice little bow
on their controversy between each other
and resolving some of the stuff i don't
know where to go with season two to be
honest with you because
it was based on
revenge
regret
atonement and deception as far as
because he kept himself hidden long
enough for him to get strong enough to
go after obi-wan so
i don't know where they go
with with this but i am very pleased
that they didn't waste not one episode
right yeah they definitely
um
took their time and delivered with each
and every episode building upon the
previous lessons learned
uh during last week and i for this show
episode for the final episode i really
enjoyed
this lightsaber battle probably one of
the best lightsaber battles that we have
seen across the entire franchise
and i enjoyed how symbolic it was that
going into it
um obi-wan was trying to put on the air
of the sacrificial lamb of doing the
good thing
but we had rokin seeing through that
like
this isn't about us
this is about you and your past that you
have to face you want to do this um you
want to
give it all if you have to
um
and i really like that when obi-wan had
that moment in the pit of
self-reflection and ultimately choosing
to push smash that confront the heart of
the manor of finally playing the words
i'm sorry i failed you um
to vader of making you how you are and
inadvertently
vader giving obi-wan that peace so this
is not you i did this and then
i'll be one
finally doing the classic jedi thing of
just letting go choosing to walk away
from it all making peace with what has
happened and literally going to a
brighter future in a different path that
would say at the very end as he's um on
the kawapi camel
um
writer outlook marching on
we finally get to see his master he's
been trying to contact his force ghost
and he's just like yeah oh i've been
waiting it took you
yeah yeah and the fact that he he's been
there but obi-wan just wasn't ready to
see i think it's super powerful that he
had to work past that to get to where he
is now and basically only step one
because qui-gon said there's a long road
ahead we have a lot of stuff to do
and
um setting up for
uh when we see obi-wan again in a new
hope and his final confrontation with
vader and once again a symbolic moment
of choosing to let go
and that vader as you said has is still
chained by his past when he was talking
with palpatine and we see that all the
way through a new hope of he never let
go of that moment
um always trying to get the better of
obi-wan even when he was anakin that was
always his drive his obsession to win
yep to be better than his master
yep and the other thing that wrapped up
in this final episode is that we see
uh riva go after the lars and luke
specifically um to fulfill her own
vengeance and ultimately uh this is one
of my favorite things of it finally put
a nice bow because during this whole
entire scene with the lars who by the
way the lars pulled up meru and owen
they were about to smoke and i was not
ready um and neither was riva um
she's because they said no we're not
gonna run
we're gonna wait because she's gonna
come at night we're gonna ambush her
he got the worst of it
[Music]
he got the worst of it but i'm yelling
inside the living room i'm yelling and a
shoot at him and then hit him in the
head with a box and he did it and i'm
like yes that's exactly how you work it
and you shoot at the same time she can't
deflect everything
it was
when she was hunting
luke
it seemed like uh
something out of um
jason or michael myers or
uh texas chainsaw cause she's limping on
one leg yeah she has the save in the
next she's running after this kid and
this kid climbs the mountain
um there's a one little plot hole in it
that um i didn't like that the fact that
obi-wan actually saw the vision of where
he was but landed still at the house but
didn't land
where exactly luke was but
that would have took away from her
actually carrying luke back
um and resolving that part uh that she
was always a youngling
and vader always knew
that what her undoing was
at this point and it was the grand
inquisitor is kind of crazy i got to see
more of him in action because i didn't
get a chance to see any of the
inquisitors in action to be honest right
um
except for her except for you know the
third sister but um
her storyline came to an appropriate end
when she drops to saba
which which i find kind of reckless like
some kid could find the same inside
you know i always think at that moment
wow everyone just bearing sabers at
tatooine i just need to go to tatooine
and just dig up some sabers um
but
it's it's
i want to know more of her journey i
want to know if she you know um goes
back because because remember she is so
powerful and enforced
you know that that's something that she
can't get rid of and you know she can't
you know um you know submerge she has to
probably go forward maybe they hunt her
next maybe she goes to uh the light side
you know um i don't know i but i do want
to know more and in
knowing the fact that we do have another
season you know that's quite a
possibility that the inquisitors
actually go to hunt her because remember
the grand inquisitor told her um
revenge is such a motivating uh factor
you know to getting well
and because he came back looking strong
as hell boy
i'm very interested if uh riva
if she goes and connects with people at
the path because we know that um the
secret underground network for
building blocks of the rebellion and
surviving jedi
uh maybe she'll meet up with quinlan vos
that'll be very interesting or even hit
up calcus in the video games like jedi
survivor because she too is now a
survivor of this war-torn tragedy and at
that moment of um redemption
i enjoy that riva uh fits a hole in that
we don't see a lot of villains in the
star wars universe be redeemed and then
have to do the work um on that path
often they're redeemed and they're
killed in the next second or they die
um it's quite a trope that's kind of
tiring and i appreciate when villains do
survive and are redeemed and then have
to put in the work and
or the
almost the my brother's keeper moment of
bringing luke back and then facing
kenobi and
in tears asking you know have i become
him of darth vader it was a parallel
storytelling to me a revenge of the sith
because i thought back to that moment
when obi-wan faced a dying anakin
shouting you became the very thing you
swore to destroy and that riva was just
one step away of becoming the person
she's hated the most and for her
for her to be reconciled by obi-wan
saying you haven't because you chose not
to was very powerful
so very much one of my favorite uh
moments in the entire episode and
overall this series
has been a journey of healing finding
oneself and then
remembering when you find yourself what
do you do from there who are you going
to become from that point on
the the craziest thing is my wife never
saw the earlier films
she only saw the the later films right
so
she didn't know that she was not gonna
kill luke
so she's scared as hell like run run
run little one run
and i'm laughing because i know that
he's not going to die right right
but
for a new audience for someone who
doesn't know all the lore
uh this was very compelling stuff
it was very compelling storytelling it
was also strategic where you saw general
kenobi come into play when he took darth
vader into tight quarters because anakin
darth vader has uh long broad strokes
when he swings his sword
but
if you take him into tight uh areas
he wasn't able to
actually attack
obi-wan as much as he was when he was in
open field so i thought that was very
strategic honest and you saw a lot of
uh kenobi thinking and using strategy in
this in in this uh
battle to be honest with you
thinking sorry yeah yeah no no i agree
that's exactly him out like during the
clone wars um obi-wan kenobi was known
as the master tactician he had a
thinking mind he always wanted to
predetermine steps and analyze the
situation and oftentimes why him and
anakin work so well is because they
balance each other out obi-wan was the
thinker and anakin was the hot shot um
doer of the team and they melded very
nicely
and you can see the clashing of forces
in that fight like you said the
different fighting styles um
darth vader he uses the very strong gem
so of saber fighting and using um his
power to
overcome the opponent punting like a
tidal wave and obi wan is much of that
patient defense turning the tide against
someone and being the last one standing
um so again beautiful art beautiful
direction by the storytelling the fight
choreography everyone who worked on the
show
and seeing little leia at the end
dressing up looking like
a new hope little blaster on hand
all that foreshadowing of being a great
resistance
leader and just so good so good
another thing about the battle which at
which you know as i'm recalling it
he always had to show anakin
how to use a particular
move weapon
or tactic
see vader use the stones
as a bludgeoning force like as as as
one like you said a tidal wave
obi
used the same rocks the same instance
but he send a whole bunch of smaller
ones at him and he pelted him to his
knees
to get him to submit
so instead of squashing the bug
he actually
beat the bug down with a rain like it's
like it's like you know trying to hit a
bug with a broom
and opposed to uh you know the rainfall
actually taking the ball the bug down so
i i i honestly now that i look back at
it i'm like wow he was calculating the
whole way through
everything that was going on within that
battle and he really wasn't at a loss he
was just trying to save his friend
great stuff great yeah yeah and that's
the journey about star wars it's always
about taking the simplest of lessons and
having that be told for a wide audience
whether you're seeing star wars for the
first time as a young child or you've
been here for a while um as an adult 40
plus years of star wars it's the
beautiful thing that disney lucasfilm
really want to make star wars for
everyone yeah
they're doing a great job
but that has been it for our coverage of
obi-wan kenobi at a lord's minute thank
you so much for joining us we're here
every monday wednesday and friday at
lords of gaming.net
i'm ty swenson here with lord king and
this has been
the lord's minute
peace
[Music]
you